what's going on guys this is rob and
uh i'm currently at lexington kentucky
i'm out of town and i know the idea was
that we would do live streams whenever
new episodes of one division came out
but i can't currently live stream
because i'm in a hotel and as you guys
know hotel wi-fi
pretty much always sucks so uh over on
pop culture explained you'll find a link
to the channel down in the description
i've got my thoughts on the uh the new
one division episode
and what i think is going on and i
thought i saw some like somebody sitting
in
the back of my truck do you guys see
anybody back there
i don't see any ghosts or anything
i'm being haunted uh so
you'll find a link to the video down in
the description um it's actually my
thoughts on wand division episode number
three
and uh really kind of an expansion on
the last video that we did in terms of
what i think is going on
because i think a lot of things are
happening but uh yeah it's it's cool
it's really fun to make
also i want to say thank you guys right
i would i would do the little hand
phrase thing like the the little prey
simple thing
uh but thank you guys you guys are
awesome um
the pop culture explain channel is
growing really really fast i never
really expected it to grow
uh so i think we're gonna lean into that
right we're gonna do a lot of like the
the comic book community or not really
comic book but like the geek culture
type stuff that we
can't really get away with on comics
explain that we'll do there um
to really kind of appeal to that right
because a lot of you guys really seem to
love it and i love doing it me and my
team
we love doing it right it's it's awesome
we really enjoy it so
make sure you guys go check that out um
and then next week
i'll be back in town and then we'll
actually do a live stream on one
division episode four
and talk about that and where i think
everything's going because here's the
thing i have a lot of theories
but i think a lot of you guys are right
about mephisto so anyway
uh i will catch you all later peace